star wars episode opens up on stars
cliche
[Music]
hey you yeah you don't you act like you
didn't just have a mild geekgasm
thinking that this doodad was a
lightsaber and were not immediately
disappointed when it turned out to be
whatever this is instead i see you i am
you also i used to have one of these but
the emergency room doctor said it didn't
survive the procedure as well as i had i
was pretty bummed i find this helmet
very confusing yes it's crucial to
protect your head in battle but what
about the rest of your body an intact
brain can only do so much with a
blaster-riddled body it doesn't suit you
that mask commenting on someone else's
personal aesthetic i'd rather walk but
it's not too bad well
we can't have a bride with dirty feet
may i be so bold as to recommend shoes i
wish my parents could be here to see
this they're one with the planet now yes
along with your parents expositional
reminiscing expo meniscing no one will
be seated as the bride remains seated
for a long scenic trek through the
doomed landscape also this montage of
mountain climbing and accompanying song
is beautiful but it takes up over a
minute of this show's precious 16 and
adds essentially nothing to the story
how can a 16-minute show possibly
require this level of padding now i read
a blog that told me these two are the
bride in the groom and they go to this
altar for their ceremony which unlocks
power through their union but see i had
to read a blog to fully understand what
was happening here so that's a sin we
are one seems ironic that being one with
majna results in being blue bald we're
making a path for the fish adding rocks
into the water is not how you make a
path for fish kids those
are the planet's memories okay if the
planet has memories i just want to be
extremely clear that everyone present my
shawarma party last thursday night were
consenting adults and the macaroni was
purely decorative so beautiful what your
feet yeah they're beautiful for sure but
now the ceremony's over so why don't you
walk on your own
and all just for war that's all that war
is nice sentiment but edwin starr said
it better
[Music]
i mean why bother coming up with
character names if you know you can get
away with hymns they and masters well
because when you do this i have no idea
what's going on or who i should give a
crap about that's why celebrations are
meant to be shared with a large group
because if you hold back you won't be
cursed wait what if you don't celebrate
with a large group of people you get
stuck with a curse so whenever you get
good news it's just a mad rush to find
the largest group of people you can
before you allow yourself to celebrate
this must be the vaguest [ __ ] curse
to have ever cursed after this the bride
and groom consummate it's tomorrow isn't
it they'll take her away oh well that's
disappointing drinking from the bottle
they wanted the village chief as
collateral
but his granddaughter volunteered to
take his place this might seem overly
pragmatic but why can't they just
appoint a new chief and why is taking
his granddaughter any more palatable
than taking him we're going to bring
them down they are not the land is on
our side it is not can you feel the
majina as well okay i think i'm going to
save myself the embarrassment in you the
energy of judging me and just add on one
sin for every imagina kind of sounds
like vagina joke that i've written for
the record this one really is the title
of my sex tape though i have a bad
feeling about this cliche what do you
think would happen if they were thwarted
covering the lower half of your main
character's face with a mask because you
can't be bothered to animate their lips
moving and
[Music]
i won't be alone i mean that's true
because you're gonna be taken by the
enemy i just can't figure out why you
seem so calm and happy about it
we're in this together he says moments
after suspiciously staring at a sharp
knife is is she safe
[Music]
nothing says ready to kick some raider
ass like cutting your hair and dropping
your mask also littering you know how
some of these episodes are 90 spaceship
porn yeah this episode skips that and
opts in for nature porn and there has to
be a middle ground somewhere
oh
yay
these guys are back these really aren't
the droids i was looking for it would
appear that she is the leader it would
also appear that she's not actually
bound and should easily be able to get
up and walk how are everyone's earrings
floating in mid-air
don't [ __ ] stand up why is he
standing up
wait why aren't they hitting them you're
droids not storm oh never mind i guess i
won't be needing this anymore
i'm assuming this chap isn't a jedi but
he [ __ ] ought to be if i'm expected
to believe he made this unbelievable
shot i think i just found my new disc
golf partner also where's this rocket
helmet storing the fuel to generate this
incredible amount of thrust and it must
be hiding a bomb in there as well to do
this much damage did mary poppins build
this thing
is mary bobbins a [ __ ] jedi high
heels in battle high heels when running
high heels on any damn occasion love
hammer toes how did he get his helmet
back exploded a damn ship for yoda's
sake i mean come on disney we can handle
losing one beloved character permanently
sometimes and so the young jedi race to
the nearest black friday sale with a
newfound understanding of her speed
shoes and the benefit they give her to
stay in the spaceship until the doors
open and still zoom to be first in line
[Music]
we're gathered here today to join
together
did we already start yeah sorry i
thought there was supposed to be a
buzzer or a whistle or something
[Music]
who are you we are the knights who say
it doesn't suit you
that mask no one cared who i was till i
put on the mask
human beings venture into the highest
parts of our planet at their peril
some might think that by climbing a
great mountain they have somehow
conquered it
but we can only be visitors here
[Music]
harry potter the boy who lived
come to die
i am a jedi
wow
last one standing wins
we are one
blue